[موسيقى]
وانا صغير لما كنت بحب اكله معينه كنت
بقعد اكلها كل يوم لمده شهر لحد لما ابقى
هرجع لو جبت لي سيرتها لما كانت بتعجبني
اغنيه كنت بحطها على الريبيت ال000 مره
لحد لما اصدع لو سمعتها تاني لما كنت بحب
شخص ما بقى كنت بستغل اسوا استغلال
وبستني لحد ما بخلي الشخص ده يكرهني تماما
كان شعاري في الحقيقه مره واحده لا تكفي
والاف المرات لن تشبع
ابدا افتكر مره وانا عندي خمس سنين كنت في
بيت العيله وكان معايا واحد قريبي اصغر
مني بسنه اسمه شريف وكان في حد جاي يزور
اهالينا فكان جايب لي انا وشريف كل واحد
كيس مليان
شيكولاته شريف عمل ايه بقى شريف طلع
شيكولاتايه من الكيس واخد منها حته ودخل
حط بقيه الكيس في الدولاب وعلى مدار اليوم
كله كان شريف واكل تقريبا شيكولاتايه
واحده انما انا بقى فاقل من نص ساعه كنت
مخلص الكيس بتاعي كله اكلت كل الشيكولاته
ودخلت على الدولاب بتاع شريف عشان اكمل ما
وقفتش لحظه فكرت قد ايه شريف ممكن يزعل
مني من حركه زي دي ما وقفتش لحظه فكرت في
كم الكالوريز الرهيب اللي دخلته في جسمي
في وقت قليل جدا كانت اهم حاجه عندي ان
انا اكون مبسوط وحالتي المزاجيه هي رقم
واحد كبرت شويه وبقى عندي تقريبا 13 سنه
وفضل نفس السلوك وشكل العلاقات في حياتي
هو هو بس متفاقم شويه كانت اهم حاجه عندي
برض ان انا اكون مبسوط بس دورت على
السعاده دي في المخدرات وقدرت انجح بجداره
في ان انا ابوظ كل العلاقات اللي في حياتي
واخلي كل الناس اللي حواليا مش قابلين
علاء في حياتهم اهلي وعيلتي واصحابي وحتى
الشريف وحتى علاقتي مع ابويا بعد اما زمان
افتكر وانا صغير كانت علاقتي بيه كويسه
جدا وكنا قرابين من بعض قوي افتكر كل شويه
كانت العلاقه بتقلب سطحيه جدا وممكن ن
اختزلها في كم كلمه او كم سؤال ازيك عامل
ايه اتعشيت طب تصبح على خير وعلى مدار
السنين كانت المسافه بيني وبينه كل شويه
بتكبر انا كنت عايش معاه زمان في اسكندريه
و وانا عندي 15 سنه قررت ان انا هروح اعيش
في القاهره مع امي ومن ساعتها بقى افتكر
العلاقه بيني وبينه ابتدت تبقى شبه معدومه
الا بشويه مكالمات بتحصل بيني وبينه كل
شويه هو كان بيجي قاهره كتير عشان يخلص
شغل كان بيكلمني كل مره وهو جاي في السكه
يقول لي ما تيجي ننزل نشرب مع بعض كوبايه
قهوه او نتغدى في النادي وحشني وعايز اقعد
اتكلم معاك شويه بس للاسف انا كان كل مره
ورايا حاجه اهم منه ان انا اعملها يا اما
واحد صاحبي مستنيني عشان نروح نسكور
يا اما متاخر على حفله يا اما الدي رواف
مستنيني على اول الشارع ولازم اروح له
المهم ان انا كان دايما ورايا مشوار اهم
من ابويا لازم
اعمله وبعد 15 سنه من الادمان النشط وبعد
اما عنت كتير جدا ان انا مش محتاج مساعده
ابتدت تتكسر حته الانكار اللي كانت عندي
لما ابتديت اجمع كم الخساير اللي شفته في
كل جوانب حياتي بعد 15 سنه باذي كل شخص
بيجي في سكتي بشكل مباشر او غير مباشر
وبطريقه مقصوده او غيرها بعد 15 سنه عايش
زي الفيروس اللي عمال بيموت كل حاجه حلوه
بتتعرض له وبرمي اللوم على كل حاجه برايا
بعد ما كان حقيقي ما عنديش اي اختيارات
تانيه وانا عندي 28 سنه قررت ان انا
هوقف وفي خلال رحله التعافي فهمت ان كل
اللي كنت اعرفه عن الادمان والصوره
الذهنيه اللي في خيالي عن طبيعه المرض ده
كلها طلعت غلط وان الادمان هو مجرد شويه
سلوكيات قهريه كنت بستخدمها في كل يوم في
حياتي عشان كده كانت كل محاولاتي ان انا
اوقف قبل كده كانت بتفشل تماما والسلوك
القهري ده هو ايه ببساطه
هو التعود الشديد على استخدام حاجه معينه
ا ان كان هو ايه نوع الادمان اكل مخدرات
قمار دين انترنت شوبن او حتى البورنوجرافي
واستخدام الحاجه دي عاده بيكون بجرعات
متزايده بغض النظر عن المصاب اللي ممكن
تحصل بسبب الموضوع ده والامتناع عن
استخدام الحاجه دي لمده معينه بيؤدي الى
ظهور اعراض عضويه ونفسيه مؤلمه جدا بتخلي
الشخص يرجع تاني غصبا عنه بشكل قهري
يستخدم بعد ما قدرت اتخطى المشكله بتاعتي
ابتديت اكتشف ان انا عليا دور ان انا
اساعد الناس ان هي تطلع من المشكله
بتاعتها باقل خساير ممكنه وان انا اساعدهم
ان هم يعيشوا حياه احسن ويكون ليه تفاعل
بناء في المجتمع فقررت ان انا هدرس
الادمان بشكل اكاديمي وافهم ليه في ناس
اكتر عرضه للتوجه للسلوك القاهري ده عن
غيرهم لانه كان عندي ايمان قوي جدا اني لو
قدرت افهم الاسباب هقدر اساعد الناس دي
بشكل احترافي اكتر وفعلا بدات شغل في مجال
علاج الادمان ودرست حاجه اسمها الدبلوما
الدوليه للتعامل مع السلوكيات الادمانيه
وانا مش بقول كلمه دوليه عشان يبان ان انا
واد جامد او حاجه ان عشان دي من اكبر
المشاكل اللي بتواجهنا هنا في مصر بلدنا
لسه ما فيهاش حاجه اسمها مهنه معالج
سلوكيات عندنا انت لو بتعالج الادمان يبقى
انت دكتور او اخصائي نفسي ومع احترام
الكامل لكل الدكاتره والاخصائيين النفسيين
انا شخصيا اكتر حاجه ساعدتني في اول رحله
التعافي هو ان انا كنت شايف قدامي شخص كان
في مكاني في يوم من الايام بس قدر ان هو
يخلص من مشكلته دي وده كان بيديني امل
كبير جدا وكان بيوصلي احساس بالمصداقيه
لانه اكتر حد هيفهم المدمن لما يجي يحكيله
انه عنده فكره او اشتياق للتعاطي او يجي
يتكلم معاه عن اكتر الافكار المريضه اللي
بتعدي في دماغه هو حد عدى بالموضوع ده قبل
كده حد يبقى فاهمه وقادر يتعرف على مشاعر
الخوف والغضب والذنب والعار حد يبقى قادر
وهو بيسمعه يحط نفسه مكانه ويقبله بدون
شروط ودي حاجات مهما ان كنت دارس مش هتبقى
كفائتها زي لما تكون مجرب المدمن هو
الاقدر على فهم ومساعده مدمن
اخر من خلال بقى قوه الاراده والعزيمه
واهم حاجه بقى مساعده ناس كتير جدا وقفت
جنبي قدرت اقدم للمجتمع النهارده اكتر
حاجه هو محتاجها في ظل الاحصائيات على
تعاطي وادمان المخدرات اللي بترتفع بشكل
مرعب قدرت اقدم الامل امل ان الادمان على
المخدرات ممكن ان يتوقف تماما امل ان في
شخص ما نزل تحت الارض ممكن انه يرجع تاني
ويبقى بني ادم منتج ومسؤول وقوه مغيره في
المجتمع اللي هو عايش فيه كان في واحد
بيتعالج في المكان اللي انا كنت شغال فيه
بس عشان احافظ على خصوصيه الشخصيه دي انا
هسميه صديقي صديقي ده قعد 10 10 سنين في
محاولات ان هو يوقف وكلها كانت بتبقى
محاولات فاشله جدا حاول يوقف بكل الطرق
مستشفيات ودكاتره ودين ومراكز اعاده تاهيل
وكل مره كان بيفشل فشل ذريع واهله كانوا
خلاص فقدوا الامل تماما فيه لدرجه ان
مامته واخواته كانوا بطلوا يتكلموا معاه
اساسا المهم صديقي المره دي قرر ان هو
يعمل حاجه مختلفه تماما اولا اخد قرار
جريء جدا هو كان شغال شغل ما كانش بيحبه
تماما على الرغم ان هو كان بيقبض فلوس
كويسه جدا فيه ال انه ما كانش قابل زمايله
في الشغل ما كانش قابل مديره ماكش قابل
المسؤوليات اللي بتتحط عليه فكان دايما
بيجي يحكيله يحكي لي انه رافض تماما
الظروف اللي هو عايشها ومش قابل الحياه
بشروطها ومش قادر يتاقلم مع الوضع
ده ف زي ما بقول لكم بقى قرر ان هو اخد
قرار جريء جدا ان هو هيسيب الشغل اللي ما
كانش عاجبه ويبعد عن جو التوتر اللي كان
مسببه له اخد قرار انه بالرغم من معامله
اهله ليه هو برده هيحسن من نفسه وفعلا
الراجل ده بدا في شغل حر فريل لانسين في
حاجه هو شاطر فيها وبيحبها وبدا يكون
علاقات مع ناس جديده في حياته وبشارك
اهتماماته وناس على نفس المستوى الفكري
بتاعه وبدا يكون في في حياته ناس بتحبه و
بيحبهم بجد وده كان مخليه دايما مستريح
نفسيا جدا فبالتالي ده كان بينعكس على
طريقته مع اهله في البيت لانه لاول مره
فكر ان هو يلتمس لاهله الاعزار بدل ما كان
كل مره بيقعد يرمي اللوم عليهم وخلاص كنت
لسه قاعد بتكلم مع صديقي من اسبوعين بيحكي
لي ان اهله بداوا يرجعوا يتكلموا معاه
تاني والنهارده صديقي ده مبطل بقى له تسع
شهور
اعتقد معظمنا عنده فكره ان الادمان هو
مجرد تعود او اعتماديه وان واحد مننا اي
شخص لو اخد جرعه من الهروين وقعد اسبوعين
بياخد نفس الجرعه وبيزود خلاص الشخص ده
بقى مدمن على المخدر ده وعلى الرغم من ان
الصوره دي فيها شق من الحقيقه الى ان ده
جزء صغير جدا جدا جدا ويمكن انجاز التعبير
ده اسهل جزء في مرض الادمان وعلاجه سنه
1964 وردش او منظمه الصحه العالميه قررت
ان هي هتست بدل مصطلح الادمان مصطلح
الاعتماديه لان هم كانوا شايفين ان لفظ
مدمن هو لفظ فيه نوع من الاهانه والازدراء
فبقى المعتقد الراسخ في فكرنا من 1964 هو
ان الادمان مجرد اعتماديه وهو مرض بيخص
الشك العضوي بس انما اي حد دارس ادمان
وسلوكيات وصحه نفسيه هيبقى عارف كويس ان
احنا المرض بنسميه ات ا بايو سايكو سوشو
سبرتال ديزيز هو مرض عضوي ونفسي واجتماعي
وروحاني يعني المرض بياثر علينا في كذا
جانب من جوانب حياتنا الجانب العضوي هو
اللي احنا كلنا متفقين عليه وهو انه جسمك
لما بيدخل له مخدر بيحسسك بالنشوه وبعدين
جسمك بيبتدي يكون تولرنس او تحمل الجرعه
اللي انت اخدتها فبالتالي كل مره بتحتاج
ان انت تزود الجرعه عشان توصل لنفس احساس
النشوه الجزء النفسي هو التمحور الكامل
حول الذات لان ساعتها الشخص ده بيكون شايف
ان هو محور الكون كله وهو وحالته المزاجيه
اهم حاجه فبالتالي بيبتدي يتصرف تصرفات
معاديه للمجتمع اما الجزء الاجتماعي هو
تدهور العلاقات الاجتماعيه تماما والاتجاه
للوحده والعزله لان الشخص بيكون شايف ان
هو غير الناس دي كلها ومش مرحب بيه في وسط
الناس دي اما الجزء الروحاني بقى وهو
الجزء المحبب الى
قلبي هو البعد التام عن الخالق ايا كان
كنت عايز تسميه ايه الروحانيات ببساطه هي
القيم والمبادئ الانسانيه اللي بنمشي
عليها واكتر حاجه كانت بتوجعني انا شخصيا
في رحله الادمان النشط هي ان انا كنت كل
شويه بقعد اكسر في المبادئ اللي اتربيت
عليها وبتنازل عن ابسط القيم اللي بتخليني
انسان
الادمان هو مجموعه معقده جدا من الظواهر
اللي لا يمكن ان احنا نختزل لسبب واحد وده
معناه ان ما فيش حل او علاج واحد بس اللي
انا متاكد منه انه شكل وضوابط العلاقه ما
بينا وما بين اي شخص عنده مشكله مع
السلوكيات القهريه هو من اهم العناصر
العلاجيه طول عمرنا بنعمل التجارب
والابحاث عن الادمان بشكل واحد ماتغيرش هو
اننا بنجيب فار بنحطه في قفص لوحده ونحط
له ازازتين ميه مايه عاديه ومايه ملوثه
بالكوكاين او الهروين بيبتدي الفار يشرب
من الميه العاديه وبعد كده يروح يجرب يشرب
من الميه المخدره وطبعا بتعجبه جدا لان هي
بتوصل له احساس نشو عالي قوي فبير كل مره
بشكل قهر يشرب من الميه المخدره دي لحد ما
بيحصل له اوفردوز وبيموت ودي كانت النتيجه
اللي بنحصل عليها كل ما بنعيد التجربه
بنفس الشكل في السبعينات قرر دكتور نفسي
اسمه بروفيسور بروس الاندر ان هو هيعمل
التجربه دي بس بشكل مختلف شويه وقرر ان هو
هيحط معطيات جديده في المعادله على امل ان
هو يحصل على نتائج مختلفه وقال انه تجربه
ال لوحده في القفص مش بتعكس البيئه
الحقيقيه للمدمن او للمجتمع اللي فيه
المدمن يعني فراح جايب قفص كبير قوي وعمل
قوض كتير قوض حط فيها اكل كتير وحلو قوض
حط فيها لعب كتير وقوض حط لهم فيها
السبيننج ويلز اللي بيتمرنوا عليها وخلى
السبيننج ويلز دي بتجر
انيرجي بتطلع طاقه بشكل معين بتنور الميز
اللي هم قاعدين فيها وراح جايب فران كتير
قوي عشان يعكس البيئه بتاعه المجتمع وحط
لهم برض اساس ميه كتير ميه عاديه ومايه
ملوثه بالمخدر واطلق على التجربه دي اسم
دراد بارك المهم بقى ان التجربه دي كانت
مغيره تماما لفهمنا عن طبيعه مرض الادمان
بحيث انه ايه بقى اللي حصل ولا فار واحد
كان بيشرب من الميه المخدره دي بشكل قهري
وولا فار واحد حصل له اوفردوز ومات فتحولت
المعادله تماما من 100% سلوك قهري وموت
بسبب جرعه زياده ل 0% ودي كانت نتيجه
صادمه لمعظم الناس اللي درست وبتشتغل في
المجال كان تفسير التغيير الجذري ده في
تفكير الفران وسلوكهم هو انه الجسم بيفرز
حاجات اصلا احنا بنسميها ده فيل جود
كيميكالز زي الدوبامين سيروتونين
اوكسيتوسين والككس دي بتفرز في جسمك بشكل
طبيعي في اوقات معينه زي لما بتاكل اكله
حلوه بتتمرن وبتلعب رياضه او في تواصل
بينك وبين الناس اللي بتحبهم لانه
الاكسيتوسن ده مسؤول عن التواصل والترابط
الاجتماعي المخدرات لما بتدخل الجسم
الماده الفعاله اللي فيها بتبعت اشارات
للمخ ان هو يفرز الدوبامين وبتروح تقف على
المستقبلات العصبيه او النيور ريسبتور
بحيث ان هي تمنع الدوبامين يرجع مخازنه
تاني فده بيحسسك احساس نشو عالي قوي
وبيستمر فتره كبيره بروفيسور بلوس
الكساندر اكتشف انه الفران لما كانت بتاكل
اكل كويس وبتلعب مع بعض وفي تواصل بينهم
وبين بعض ما كانوش محتاجين للمخدر او اي
عوامل خارجيه ان هي تحسسهم بالنشوه لان
الكلز دي كانت بتفرز بشكل طبيعي فطلع
بمقوله شهيره جدا بعد ما التجربه اتعملت
كذا مره واثبتت نجاح وقال انه عكس الادمان
مش التعافي عكس الادمان هو التواصل
والترابط الاجتماعي ناس كتير جدا شككت في
التج دي ساعتها وقالت ان المدمن هيفضل
مدمن زي ما هو حتى لو في ناس بتحبه وبيحبه
وحتى لو في نوع من العلاقات الصحيه في
حياته انما الحسن الحظ كان في تجربه
انسانيه شبيهه للرا بارك وتقريبا كانت في
نفس الوقت ايام حرب فيتنام كان في تقارير
بتترفع انه اكتر من 20% من المجندين
الامريكان بيتعاطوا وادمن الهروين كان في
تخوف كبير جدا ان المجندين دول لما
هيرجعوا امريكا هيبقى فيه رقم مهول من
المدمنين في الشوارع وده كان عامل زعر
وقضيه راي عام بس بس اللي حصل المجندين
دول لما رجعوا امريكا من غير اي حاجه ما
دوروش على المخدر تاني ووقفوا لما اتغيرت
البيئه بتاعه القفص المرعب اللي كانوا
عايشينه في فيتنام للقفص اللي هم بيحبوه
وهو بيتهم واسرتهم الحاجه للمخدرات ببساطه
اختفت واقل من 5% بس من الناس دي هي اللي
احتاجت برامج اعاده
تاهيل وعشان الادمان بيخص كل واحد فينا
احنا كلنا محتاجين نفهم اهميه العلاقات
الانسانيه في حياه اي مدمن لانه ممكن يكون
اخوك اختك باباك مامتك جارك او حتى زميلك
في الشغل احنا محتاجين ما نوسم المدمنين
وصمه عار ما نرفت من شغلهم ما نطردهم من
بيوتنا ما نبعدهم مش عننا قد ما نقدر على
امل ان ده ممكن يساعدهم ان هم يوقفوا لان
في الحقيقه ده بيساعدهم ان هم يتمادوا
اكتر في السلوكيات دي عشان بكده احنا
بنهدد بقطع العلاقات معاهم ويمكن هي دي
الحاجه الوحيده اللي لسه بتديهم سبب يصحوا
عشانه تاني
يوم احنا محتاجين نضم الشخص اللي عنده
مشكله مع السلوكيات القهريه ونفهمه ان هو
مش محتاج يشيل مشاكله كلها لوحده بعد
النهارده واننا معاه وهنسا عده لانه لو
فضل زي الفار اللي كان لوحده في القفص كل
اللي حواليه رافضينه ومشاعر الخوف والقلق
والاكتئاب مسيطره على تفكيره هتكون ردود
افعاله كلها مدمره لنفسه لان هي بتكون
محاولات فاشله لتعويض الاحساس بالدونيه
وانعدام القيمه فنهايته دايما هتبقى
معروفه السجون المصحات النفسيه او الموت
وته لي جي الوقت عشان نفهم ان المدمنين مش
بيخافوا من الموت المدمنين بيخافوا من
الحياه ولازم ما خوفهم اكتر من
[تصفيق]
كده النهارده بعد ما وقفت وابتديت ارجع
العلاقات بالناس اللي في حياتي تاني اللي
بحبهم نفسي ارفع سماعه التليفون على ابويا
واقول له ما تيجي يا عم نشرب كوبايه
القهوه اللي كان نفسك فيها وندردش سوا بس
للاسف هو اختار ان هو يسيب الدنيا دي قبل
اما انا اختار ان انا اوقف اللي جاي
النهارده اقوله انه التعافي ما فتحش ابواب
الجنه مثلا ودخلني فيها بس اللي انا متاكد
منه ان فتح ابواب جهنم وخرجني منها
النهارده انا مبطل بقي لاث سنين وثلاث
شهور و2 يوم
[تصفيق]
والنهارده هو اي حد عدى بالمشكله دي بيعها
باليوم ممكن ي ده بالثانيه كمان لان
الموضوع بيبقى صعب شويه ف اللي عايز اقوله
ان النهارده اهم يوم فيهم لاني مختار ان
انا افضل برض مبطل شكرا ان انتم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
سمعتوني